we've been teaching English to preschool
children now for over 20 years we've got
a long-standing history of expertise and
well trained and experienced teachers
classes are structured around a specific
routine it's very important for children
to have routines in their life and
especially in the foreign language
learning classroom because it means that
language is repeated over and over again
in familiar situations it's happy and
enjoyable because they're learning
English in a familiar situation through
familiar activities arts and crafts up
the children because it's a positive
learning environment its interactive and
it's collaborative task is structuring
them and the language and they're
naturally seeking questions and answers
and it gives an opportunity for the
teacher to bridge their first language
english as a very important focus on
developing the whole child it's not just
about learning a language in
communicating but there's also on
learning how to interact with others how
to be socially responsible how to be
aware of their behavior and how that can
affect others so this is also important
part of the course and it's an important
part that we teach them through the
early years plus cost
you